to the Terry lecture second of three
Terry lectures by Judith Farquhar
I'm Tom NIR and I teach and perform
research at Yale through the department
of ecology and evolutionary biology as a
member of the Terry lecture committee it
is my privilege to welcome you to the
second of these three Terry lectures
presented by Judith Farquhar
collectively entitled reality reason and
action in and beyond Chinese medicine
Judith Farquhar is an American
anthropologist who studies traditional
medicine popular culture and everyday
life in contemporary China she has
published papers foking on focusing on a
diverse range of anthropological areas
including medical anthropology the
Anthropology of knowledge and of
embodiment critical theory and critical
studies and the theories of reading
writing and translation professor
Farquhar is the Max poleski
professor emeritus in the Department of
Anthropology and the college at the
University of Chicago and also serves as
a faculty director at the University of
Chicago's Center in Beijing before
arriving at the University of Chicago
she taught at McGill University and the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
professor Farr choirs lectures draw on
the science and practice of traditional
Chinese medicine to address enduring and
challenging ontological epistemological
and ethical questions from the Western
perspective Chinese medicine is often
viewed as mystical or superstitious and
its efficacy has been a matter of naive
has been thought of as a a matter of
naive faith by contrast professor Farr
choirs lecturers consider how the modern
rationalized in scientific field of
traditional Chinese medicine constructs
its very real objects that is body's
symptoms medicines drugs and how experts
think through and sort out pathology and
health and how contemporary doctors act
responsibly to humanistic ethical ends
seeking out the route of bodily disorder
the first lecture presented an approach
to understand the myriad of things of
classic Chinese metaphysics all of
Professor Farr choirs teri lectures
contributes to the thesis that
systematic Chinese men
which is no longer superstitious or a
pseudoscience can become a philosophical
ally and a rich resource to a more
capricious science will you please join
me in providing a warm welcome to
Professor Farquhar thank you so much Tom
I love the way you change that word too
capricious from capacious the patient's
eyes but capricious is good too okay um
thanks everybody
I see some of you I've come back and
that's very gratifying we're going to
move forward and I hope that some of the
foundation that I laid in lecture one is
not too much missed by those of you who
weren't here the first time oh no
there's something wrong with this slide
oh no this this it looks good on the
screen but it's not working okay I'm
gonna have to read this and skip this
slide all right this is my epigraph for
the for the talk it's a small saying
called medicine that translates as
medicine is thought eegah yeah all right
I have another slide later I hope it
works when we really have to discuss
this but medicine is thought all right
and my first lecture I observed the
diagnosis in biomedicine refers to a way
of knowing apart and suggested the
Chinese medical ways of knowing are able
to recognize living things as things
even while they're fully embedded in
active vital systems and I spoke of
medical things diseases and patterns
organs and visceral systems as being
composed and assembled even as they are
being perceived or discovered to know
life's processes without dissecting the
dead to understand our bodies events
without controlling variables in Allah
or a clinical trial this requires a kind
of disciplined perception that is not
only Chinese rather it is pre-eminently
practical and clinical Chinese medicine
is not the only form of medicine that
knows how to know in the clinic while
encountering a living person and being
required to act far from it I quoted
Nathan 7 and lecture 1 as he argued that
medicine everywhere is more an art than
a science but modern traditional Chinese
medicine being required in the mid
twentieth century to construct a
national curriculum that could produce
good doctors has perforce been
self-conscious about about how the art
and science of clinical knowing should
be structured and cultivated my research
has learned much from Chinese medicines
modern pedagogical orderliness and
philosophical reflexivity i've been so
lucky 20th century leaders in the
development of Chinese medicine have
been not only scientists and clinicians
they have also been teachers and
philosophers and they have written a lot
about their practice so bear with me as
I continue in this lecture to translate
from their discourse their world and
their practice of both teaching and
healing ok that one worked at least in
the first lecture I mentioned a modern
logical approach to the clinical
encounter known as bien Jolla Lunger
pattern discernment and therapy
determination this diagram summarizes
some disciplined habits of thought or
forms of reasoning that have
characterized the practice of many TCM
doctors trained since the 1960's TCM is
the modern abbreviation for traditional
Chinese medicine for those who are
uncomfortable with the epistemological
cutting involved in the knowing a part
of biomedical diagnosis the Angela under
this system offers what might be called
Cognos Asst or knowledge through
recognition of pattern knowing together
we could say in lecture 1 I also
discussed the thing
that is the target of this knowing
together process the pattern or jeong-ho
that forms a gathered or composed thing
a constellation of processes that are
all too real and which clinical artistry
knows as a resonating network of
pathophysiological events this one
worked okay in today's lecture inspired
by the position stated in this lectures
epigraph eje medicine is thought I want
to explicate some of the thinking
involved in the practical work of
Chinese medicine once again the verbs
will be important gathering perceiving
appreciating choosing among
possibilities inferring reasoning and
more and in keeping with Chinese grammar
both ancient and modern some nouns will
have to be turned into verbs working in
translation through some basic logics
and actions of the clinical encounter I
want to first explain modes of inference
that link manifest signs to unseen
pathologies and then consider how a
patterned illness process can be
discerned and named but first so we
don't forget that we're talking about
thought and reasoning in general let's
look at the verb in my epigraph and this
saying medicine is thought this is an
ancient phrase that has recently been
often invoked by those in China who
would make philosophy from medicine the
verbal form in eg ax is the most basic
copula of classical Chinese this
syntactically yeah at the end of the
phrase that characterizes and defines a
thing by pointing to another thing eje
ax has an emphatic quality a tone of
clearing away the cobwebs and stating
the obvious fact which we are in danger
of missing medicine really after all
boils down to nothing but thinking
really period right and this copula
works both ways logically thought is
also a kind of medicine or at least
among the varieties of thought medicine
is an important subset that is the realm
of thought includes medicine and it's
important to know that ej yeah
thus beautifully
my task in this lecture to persuade you
that any thinking person should want to
grasp how Chinese medicine thinks so let
me turn now to some modern Chinese
medical thinking about thought and
incidentally about pathology in 1935 an
influential historian publisher and
medical practitioner named eggwin wrote
a lapidary history and explication of
traditional Chinese medicine it's a
small book written in concise and
resonant classical Chinese and it was
influential for a while although it
never achieved the fame I think it
deserves at the time she was writing his
field was in crisis with millions of
medical practitioners throughout China
having just narrowly escaped an
attempted national ban on their work by
modernizing biomedical interests China
was already at war with the Japanese and
the nation was deeply divided by
warlordism and the struggle between the
nationalist and communist parties the
proponents of what was then called
national medicine had little time and
few resources to advance the modernizing
and conserving and also nationalist
agenda that many of them shared
heightened politics notwithstanding
Chuang was a scholar and a theorist he
liked to insist that medicine is thought
another of his pithy slogans is also
frequently cited in Chinese medicine
today Lee Fong Yao patterning method
composing and medicines
it was often asserted to me when I was
first studying Chinese medicine in
Guangzhou in the early 1980s that these
four words lee fong yao epitomized the
essence of the field I didn't get this
at all at the time my awkward
translation here indicates how
miscellaneous and inadequate this phrase
appeared to me it did not seem to be
summing up an essence of any kind but
I'm sticking with the awkward
translation for various reasons lately
I've been reflecting on these words
after reading shag Wong's brilliant
intellectual history in which he
proposed this slogan let's look at the
first component of his four term list
Lee is a much used term of vast
importance in the history of Chinese
philosophy though its most primitive
meaning is pattern as in the grain of
wood or the current of a stream it has
long been translated by philosophers
especially those steeped in
neo-confucian metaphysics as principle
but that translation over idealizes the
concept even as it was used by the most
metaphysical of Chinese philosophers to
my mind a principle is not the same as a
pattern and a pattern is a more material
kind of thing by contrast with this
translational idealism I cannot resist
giving of the list of short glosses
provided in my online Chinese English
dictionary is texture or grain this is a
pretty concrete thing right even if it's
not a free-standing object inner essence
intrinsic order is this hinting at the
idealism of principle and inherent
platonic form reason logic truth science
especially Natural Science and
especially physics actually these are
modern translations of Li and at this
point the dictionary shifts to the
everyday beneath philosophy li means to
manage to pay attention to to run
Affairs to handle to put in order to
tidy up this latter list reflects the
fact that Li is a verb form in everyday
life and must straighten up my desk I
should conform my checkbook to the bank
statement that sort of thing and it's
even more interesting in the negative
don't mind me the bully wha I'm just
along for the ride
if Li is all these philosophical and
mundane things at once and if it is used
as a verbal which is pretty clear and
leaf off ano in that phrase then it
helps us quite a bit as we tried to
think Chinese medical thinking
and it helped shag Juan as he tried to
modernize and summarize Chinese medicine
note again the structure of the phrase
and might be characterized as verb
result verb result two predicates with
medicine as the implicit subject of both
what Chinese medicine does share was
saying is more or less abstractly reason
its way to a method then following that
method compose a drug formula that is a
prescription only then can it assemble
the very concrete bundle of medicines
that will be handed over to the patient
I will return to the work of composing
drugs together in form formulas in
lecture 3 and the last term Yao
medicines reminds us of the question of
the thing that I considered in the first
lecture herbal medicines are very
concrete things quite salient to the
practicing doctor and each of them has a
history showing it as resulting from a
very complex gathering and knowing
practice but of these four words Li is
the most powerful notion by the 20th
century modernist ideas about Reason
logic truth and science ruled in China
by adopting for Chinese medicine a
philosophical term that it encompassed
modern science reason and truth while
dragging along with it a long history
and a vast literature in Chinese which
is to say retaining the terms primary
meaning as pattern eggwin was being very
canny indeed when I reflect on and read
about the historical moment in which in
which eggwin was writing I must conclude
she was making an early gesture in the
invention of a theory practice divided
for China he was not alone the political
pressures that were making theory into a
thing underpinning an ancient clinical
art are too complex for me to describe
here but some policymakers at the time
were arguing for keeping the effective
herbal drugs of Chinese medicine and
discarding everything else especially
the traditional thinking of the field
what's interesting about this is that
everyone who does a history of 20th
century Chinese medicine points out that
there was this mid-south
movement to throw out all that all the
thinking all the theory and to keep the
drugs however what they don't notice is
that nobody before she iguana was really
talking about theory or a theory and
practice divided so the theory and
practice suddenly but looks like a very
modern couple it's not something that
you could find everywhere in every
knowledge regime throughout history but
it's not an accident that she iguanas
leaf a falling out took hold in the
1930s and was still urged on me as an
important banner for Chinese medical
development 50 years after chef first
voiced his formula he and his
contemporaries realized as their nation
struggled toward modern statehood a
modern science must have so-called
theoretical foundations
it must be rational but a
self-consciously traditional medicine
must find its rational foundation in
classical philosophy in formulas like
this one the field was both resisting
and exemplifying science look again at
our forwards there is an immensely
complex stance involved in the way that
patterning ly is thought to produce a
method a specific form of intervention
in illness and this stance is repeated
as the structured composition of the
formula yields a collection of things
which is to say a bundle of drugs
medicines you can take home and boil up
theory practice theory practice a
science both ancient and modern declares
itself in this phrase only or the grain
of reasoning rules in the field of
medicine
now having promised some empirical
answers to how medical reasoning might
work let's focus on the discerning
patterns side the left side of my master
diagram beginning with the four
examinations the importance of this step
in the process was recently reinforced
for me less than a month ago I
accompanied a group of American
undergraduate students to visit a
Chinese medical clinic clinic in Beijing
our group was lucky to be hosted by a
senior doctor who was a very tolerant
patient by his
side gave a brief lecture introducing
the field of Chinese medicine what dr.
ping most wanted to emphasize in the
context of this rather markedly
traditional private clinic was the four
examinations he proceeded to demonstrate
by performing them on the patient
examining the tongue palpating the pulse
drawing our attention to facial color
rehearsing a bit of the patient's
history like so many other experts I've
spoken with over the years he obviously
considered the discipline perception
enabled by the four examinations to be
the foundation of Chinese medical
thinking dr. Peng was showing us a
widely taught even a required protocol
for clinical work in traditional
medicine but why would the four
examinations made into a protocol we
could also ask why are there only four
in practice these four modes of clinical
observation limit the infinite
information that can be gleaned from a
sufferers body and history even
something is apparently straightforward
as a human body is what William James
called a quasi chaos he figures his
quasi chaos is a kind of unknowable
physical core around which floats a vast
cloud of experiences only some of which
can become part of the perceptual
experience of another for example a
diagnostician limits are essential in a
medical encounter as I recognize every
time I talk to my doctor and leave her
clinic a little uncertain whether she
understands all aspects of my condition
some of our experiences are worth no
medical attention after all while other
symptomatic conditions which might not
be conscious experiences at all must be
tricked into showing themselves for
example with ultrasound big momma ters
and blood tests anyone who hopes to know
anything in a medical quasi chaos it's
much like Alice playing croquet through
the looking-glass with a curious
flamingo for a mallet and a scared
Hedgehog for a croquet ball Chinese
medical philosophy is vitalist that's
why Joseph Needham the biochemist on
in the first lecture devoted his
scientific life to his particular forms
of morphogenesis I think this field
knows that the world is endlessly giving
birth to life and ceaselessly
transforming transformations this Zhang
Zhang hua hua is the fundamental process
of the universe coming into being both
from the very beginning and everyday in
our mundane reality philosophers of
Chinese medicine emphasized this idea to
emphasize their distance from a world of
fixed and immutable material objects if
we note that Alice trying to play the
game according to rules that keep
changing is herself as unknown and
unpredictable as are her mallet flamingo
and Hedgehog ball not to mention the
impulsive Red Queen nearby then we get
an idea of why the most important form
of action and medical diagnosis might be
a disciplined limitation of what is
perceptible in a universe that is
constantly emerging as myriad things
from the Hidden Springs of the great way
the DAO in a landscape full of things
that constantly metamorphose or change
into each other and create new forms
some disciplining of perception would
seem to be required before examinations
impose a discipline but they also
collect quite a lot of information as
can be seen in this slide please don't
try to memorize it it's just here as a
kind of example right
these methods are looking listening
smelling asking and palpating here I
summarize some of the categories of
information that are collected through
the four examinations this is a protocol
that is attentive to a great deal of
patience and doctor experience colors of
tongue range from carmine to nearly
black with tongue coding that can have
not only different colors but qualities
like dryness thickness grease eNOS
patchiness etc there are 28 possible
pulse qualities discernible at 18
possible sites on the wrists there are
differential breathing sounds and weird
voice sounds to be listened to
and then there are the reported
qualities of urine and stool sleeping
patterns experiences of appetite and
indigestion grumpiness or euphoria
excessive dreams goes on and on the four
examinations amount to a phenomenology
of pathological process they collect
aspects of the patient's experiences of
disorder expertly perceiving and
discriminating qualities perceptible on
the surface of a life in a kind of
radical empiricist mode of attention but
studying this list you might protest
your primary care physician here in New
Haven or a medical student studying
physical examination and history taking
would quickly point out that this method
fails to catch many important things
exact readings of blood pressure and
body temperature are missing these are
the heartbeat nor the optic fundus nor
the cervix is examined neurological
reflexes are not tested and of course
every structure that would be visualized
with x-rays CT scanning and MRI remains
in the dark this last figure of speech
and real situation helps us to see
something important about that dark
space of the body interior the four
examinations collect surface
manifestations almost exclusively
especially if we consider that the
patient's verbal account of his
symptomatic experiences he had another
kind of manifestation made present in
speech in the moment of the clinic for
the consideration of the doctor modern
Chinese medicine has only partly adopted
the visualizing technologies that help
biomedicine detect our body's silent
lesions the tumor the malformed optic
nerve the colonic pollen and this
neglect of technology could be seen as a
failure and a shortcoming of the field
but Chinese medical polemicists point
out in parallel that biomedicine lacked
sophistication in both diagnostics and
systematics so-called Western medicine
is deaf to the many qualities resonating
through the wrist pulses and disorders
of the whole body metabolic or immune
system disease for
example have to be thought about and
managed piecemeal at best with drug
cocktails rather than treated rationally
as a pattern in Chinese medical terms
how do the four examinations fit into
Chinese medical knowing practice
what role did they play in a reasoning
process what part of lee fong al are
they it is easy to see them as a kind of
medical semiotic s-- which is to say a
disciplined way of reading signs reading
for meaning we might even say we're all
familiar with this form of reading
whether or not we're physicians
suffering from a bad cold lower back
pain migraines a touch of senile
dementia we put together a narrative
that explains why this set of symptoms
and there are always several has
happened now together to me and not to
my family and friends and we extend this
narrative to predict hopefully how long
it will take for our symptomatic
discomforts to change or go away but the
stories we tell ourselves as patients
and sufferers are idiosyncratic and
unreliable compared to those that are
developed in the pattern discerning
process before examinations yield
information the Chinese doctors can
reason with understood as signs of
pathological processes affecting the
whole body the set of signs they collect
is placed in relation to the knowledge
accumulated in China's famous 2,000
years of medical experience this is a
set phrase in ways to which we will soon
turn if I'm told that I suffer from
deficient spleen function with damp heat
as I have been in fact and as dr. pings
patient was told when I visited that
clinic in August I might still feel that
my Chinese doctor has failed to see the
whole picture of my personal afflictions
but given that the pattern that dr.
discerns can yield a carefully crafted
intervention a formula and medicines
tailored to the state of
pathophysiological play in my body which
he has inferred in a skilled reading I
have to be impressed with the
sensitivity of his account of my body
and its
but let me approach this emphasis on the
four examinations and note in the
knowing practice of which they are a
part in a slightly more historical way I
want to share a few statements from a
small that absolutely classic 1959 book
called introduction to Chinese medicine
these excerpts are from the preface
written by the author Jimbo way an
important founder of modern Chinese
medicine the Chinese Communist Party has
long emphasized our nation's medical
heritage telling us Chinese medicine and
pharmacy is a great treasure house I
included the sentence only because if I
emitted omitted it those of you who know
China in the 1950s would say she's not
reading from the 1950s this is an
obligatory sentence has to be there when
Chinese medicine treats disease it
centrally relies on an integrated set of
therapeutic methods consisting of
patterning and method composing and
medicines this is our old friend lee
fong Yong I recognize the surface
appearances of Chinese medicine from
these four aspects through them we can
understand Chinese medicine specificity
and grasp Chinese medicines regular
patterns of treating illness and thus
adopt the most correct method of
studying Chinese medicine so in this
books account the various topics are
divided up under the four sections Lee
Lewin method all three
Leland methodology vod's a formulary
Fung G and pharmaceuticals yahwah so as
to give a more detailed introduction
several things interest me about this
preparatory remark of course I'm happy
to see historian shag wons pithy formula
of leaf upon yao recapitulated so
prominently and under the aegis of the
People's Republic of China's Ministry of
Health after 25 years just as it was
repeated to me by my authoritative
teachers in a 1980s Chinese medical
college and I like to note that says Lee
of the 1930s as by 1959 been transformed
into the modern term for theory Leland
really I could have done these Terry
lectures just by giving you translations
from Chinua waste little book
introduction to Chinese medicine it's
quite brilliant
he also defines refines and explains the
methodology of discerning patterns and
determining therapies taking it up at a
crucial moment in its development as a
ruling logic for the field
all the while linking this clinical
methodology to leaf off on now and
insisting on certain Chinese
specificities of reasoning and knowing
but what really impressed me about this
quote from Chen's preface was his
mention of surface appearances the word
he used for this is not a medical word
and as far as I know hardly anyone later
picked up this notion for their writing
about the four examinations or any other
component of the pattern discerning and
therapy determining process perhaps the
reading process characteristic of
medical semiotic s-- was already too
firmly established as a method of
reasoning to merit any particular
comment this would also be the case for
Western medicine by the way as dr.
summers pointed out last week after my
first talk but look at the logic of this
statement perhaps like dr. ping in the
clinic I visited last month dr. Chynn is
here putting his recognition of
appearances at the foundation of his
thinking practice he processes what
appears on the surface through pattern
method formula and even drugs to deal
with the even more defining task of
reading signs in the process this
becomes knowing from experience the
disciplined for examinations are the
beginning of discernment their signs
present themselves to be read on the
surfaces of bodies and in patients
accounts of illness experienced in the
modernist Natural Sciences especially
perhaps the experimental regimes of bio
science surface appearances are felt to
be deceiving
my clinical interviewer in Chicago
ignores my firm belief that my medical
history is going to be just like my
paternal aunts because I happen to know
that we are very much alike the doctor
wants to know only the health history of
my pack
and siblings facts that seem relevant to
the suffer from jet lag or irritable
bowel syndrome say can be treated as a
distraction or even a delusion by the
evidence-based medical expert
experimental science must rip aside the
veil of what seems to be the case
surface relationships must be critically
carved away through control of variables
and statistical analysis but in the
traditional Chinese sciences here I use
these terms traditional and science very
deliberately actually appearances cannot
be banished rather what is manifest on
the surface of things is the only
reliable guide leading us to a deeper
understanding of life so let's talk
about manifestations images and how to
read them in these lectures we've seen
shinb always surface appearances before
and the word we've used for them Shaw
has been often been translated as image
the four examinations list I just showed
you name some images pulse image and
tongue image are very important as dr.
ping emphasized with regard to visceral
systems imagery which is summarized on
this table which you saw the last time
Jung is a visible image that makes a
visceral activity apparent examples
might be a flush in the face where the
heart system manifests or bloodshot eyes
where the liver system vents the name
for this way of thinking visceral
systems imagery presumes that hidden
visceral networks throw up an image that
can be perceived by the senses of an
observer the most thoughtful and witty
usage of the word shown also appeared in
lecture 1 when I talked about dr. Liu
Guang shins word for object or thing
which was Joyce Jung or the image we
face this last notion is the most
suggestive for our efforts to understand
ways of thinking and reading and
translating and even intervening why
because the hearing must dip once again
into metaphysics the active cosmos
throws up appearances it's not just the
images we need to apprehend if we are to
intervene an illness
it is the process by which they are
generated and to which they lead our
thinking Chinese medicine holds that
pathological and physiological processes
of the whole body are more unitary and
more coherent more holistic the modern
theorists say then the miscellany of
myriad phenomena illness signs that
present themselves to our human senses
the endless transformative life process
has its patterns its grain or current
and these can be gross grasped by the
skilled doctor of course as I've argued
even ignorant patients like me have
their hunches and stories about what's
really going on inside their bodies but
the kind of medical knowing that can
effectively read all those images link
the manifestations to their hidden
sources is disciplined the doctors
perception becomes medically conceptual
Chairman Mao might say when he links the
results of the four examinations to the
analytical systems available in the
Chinese medical archive I will show that
these analytics are pre-eminently
correlative and classify as such they
rely on conventional or traditional
kinships and distinctions mobilizing
several great systems of natural linkage
and discontinuity let me approach this
so-called correlative science by listing
a few of the pattern discerning logical
technologies that are popular in clinics
of Chinese medicine these days and then
showing them at work in a description of
a well-known pattern here are some of
the analytic systems that are ready to
hand for the Chinese doctor eight
rubrics for sectors six channels
visceral systems and Jing Qi and blood
I've I've not included all possible ones
these is just first didactic reasons I'm
keeping it simple one of these you may
already have some hunches about after
having seen my table summarizing the
five visceral systems in lecture one the
slide I used then summarizing the
network connections traditionally
associated with each of the five great
visceral
gives you an idea of the kind of
correlations and distinctions that might
be invoked as clinical understanding
moves from the perceptible image to the
underlying systematic process it would
be rare to analyze a presenting illness
with reference only to visceral systems
however this series of three slides list
some of the conventional correlations of
six of the eight rubrics an analytic
technique that is almost always
considered just about any sign can be
classified as I'm going to go back cool
or warm shallow or deep repletion or
depletion and the fourth couple of
rubrics yin and Yan follow the first
three sets quite logically if you
understand yin and Yan I'm not showing
those Carleen you you can see the
connections but I'm not showing those
correlations just to keep things a
little simpler and though the
classification of facts collected in the
four examinations is falling under one
or another of the eight rubrics they
sometimes intuitively obvious a fever
and dry mouth are clearly warm and young
basically the correlations are
conventional and traditional in Maoist
idiom they arise from the several
thousand years of recorded experience of
the masses struggle against disease and
they need to be memorized by the medical
student and kept in mind by the
practitioner let's get just a little
closer to the actual clinical work with
an example suppose the patient presents
with some heart symptoms such as
palpitations a correlation in the heart
visceral system is easy to guess but
this initial punch doesn't take you very
far and it only enhances your curiosity
about other possible signs of pathology
taking the pulse you note that the
qualities of pulsation are slender and
weak
these conventionally by correlation tell
you to expect that Qi and blood are both
depleted and you might also note the
confirming fact that the patient's face
is pale nearly grey looking at the time
you observed that the body of the tongue
is unusually pale
a sign you can correlate under the
rubrics depletion and cold recall that
these are two of the eight rubrics if
the tongue coding is at the same time
white this indicates again that she and
blood might be simultaneously depleted
invoking Chi and blood we can see that
the Jing T blood analytic is also
brought to bear this is not such a
deep-seated disorder however that Jing
essence would be considered to be
affected and there's no evidence on
examination that non blood fluids are
depleted either this is a little
technical note that I cannot like I have
to always include these things because
it's part of the thinking at about this
point you'll be thinking that since the
heart rules the blood in the vessels and
vents at the tongue and manifests in the
face well you pretty much landed on a
fairly standard pattern part qi
depletion then when you turn to the
asking examination you can perhaps
impress the patient by asking whether he
is often forgetful perspires for no
reason
or has difficulty sleeping how did you
know patients sometimes ask well how did
you know perhaps from having memorized
masses of correlations and being fast on
your feet as you classify the
miscellaneous signs presented by the
patient with your correlational work you
perform a sort of differential diagnosis
you determine that the syndrome is not
yet deep-seated and for example the
blood storage functions of the liver
system and that a general pattern of
exhaustion is more due to a shortfall of
young stimulus into a buildup of Yin
substance the pattern identified is now
well characterized and set to be linked
to a therapeutic intervention patterns
of disorder are very numerous indeed
this is only one of thousands that are
in the literature almost infinite in
theory even the conventional used
analytic methods are too many in a sense
every pattern discerning practitioner
must navigate among many attractive and
overlapping options to arrive at a set
of correlations and
a pattern that persuades both him and
the patient like heart Chi depletion
patterns are discerned and named in a
way that shows them to those who know to
be convergences of more general
processes and these processes known as
physiology and pathology and modern
Chinese medicine must be understood if
there's to be any successful medical
interruption of a disordered flow
nudging the body toward better health
okay I have a conclusion now I began
this lecture with the proverb drawn from
a very early source the 5th century book
of the latter Han EJ yeah ok though
there is reason to believe that this
formula has been invoked from time to
time in the long history of Chinese
medical argumentation it recently was
made salient again by a writer of
Chinese medical theory Leo you twin
writing in 2006 by the way
EJ yeah is the title of his 2006 book
subtitled knowing Chinese medicine here
is a part of this modern authors comment
on the classical texts following Wu's
time which was the first century Common
Era when he argued that failures to cure
happened mainly when thinking is absent
following Wu's time a famous master of
the southern dynasty dynasty Tao home
Jing who lived in the 5th century
articulated rather early that medicine
is thought the book of the latter Han
States thus it was the Tao intimated
medicine is thought those who were known
as good doctors of old because they
applied limits to their capacity for
thinking they were able to know and
treat the patient all their thoughts
arose from the moment so they didn't
woodenly adopt traditional formulas to
treat the illness by implication they
treated every medical formula and
strategy they they crafted every medical
formula and strategy to the particular
pattern they were able to discern
through thought note that they applied
limits to their capacity for thinking
discipline to their imaginations this
limits issue came up before today
in my discussion of the four
examinations Chinese medicines tools of
perception and conception are very rich
but not infinitely so and they're
limited on purpose
this classic source seems to say the
author goes on summarizing the above it
was really after the Song Dynasty that
would be about 1000 that doctors
frequently pointed out that medicine is
thought the Taiping Shanghai Fong sacred
remedies of the Taiping lays it out yes
medicine is thought illness is born on
the inside and medicines adjust from the
outside doctors illuminate the pattern
of illness and medicines act on it like
a god this magical efficacy arises from
engagement with the sorts of phenomena
and from my new participation in the
transformations and the changes this is
the way of subtlety the very limit of
thought and use this brilliant summation
from more than a thousand years ago
completes the point I wanted to make in
this lecture and because it cannot do
otherwise for a pragmatist like me it
also leads us toward lecture 3 on the
nature of human medical action let me
conclude for today then by paraphrasing
this lapidary list in the language I've
been developing in these lectures this
is my paraphrase yes medicine is purely
and simply a way of thinking pathology
has its genesis on the inside of our
bodies but it expresses itself in
science on the surface and in human
experience medicines on the other hand
are brought to bear to adjust the course
of the illness process from the outside
it is the doctors job to brilliantly
perceive the pattern of disorder and if
he does the herbal medicine medicines he
composes can magically affect the
pathological process the humors
effectiveness arises from his intimate
grasp of the traditional correlations
and classifications and from her
intimate attention to the unceasing
transformations of living experience
this way brings us near to the sightless
things and it is fundamentally pragmatic
medicine is the limb
case of thought and use so I'll stop
there and get ready for tomorrow so I
think we have time for questions so we
just ask that if you have a question
it'd be a question not a statement and
go ahead and line up take we could take
the questions at either the microphones
here in the aisles I was thinking about
how Western medicine is really divided
into three aspects the physical the
mental and the emotional can you comment
on how Chinese medicine looks at the
emotional and mental illness they don't
divide it up that way but I sort of
chose some of those symptoms lists to
indicate that what we think of as
cognitive or emotional symptoms are
lumped right in there in the for
examination and so the the doctor is
thinking about the whole body and
tomorrow I'm gonna talk about a symptom
like panic attack which is considered to
be anyway not physical right in our
clinics but it's it's definitely a
symptom and it's taken very seriously by
Chinese doctors and they will look for
correlated phenomena you know they'll
look for physical phenomena like
sweating or you know feeling of
compression in the chest so that they'll
they and and actually if you think about
it every time you're having a mental
health episode we all have them of
course think about how you feel in your
whole body you know I mean don't you
feel short of breath
isn't there a kind of pressure in your
chest don't you have weird aches and
pains these kinds of symptoms are not
simply thought to be epiphenomena to the
psychological crisis by a Chinese
they're part of the pattern and they
have to be taken very seriously so the
divide is not there now today of course
we have lots of Chinese medical doctors
who are specializing in emotional
disorders and there but they're there a
lot of them are doing it by re
translating present modernists emotional
disorders into a classical holistic
language of a whole body disorder and
they and that and then they can write an
herbal prescription that should help
make sense yes I was just thinking that
the other one the other sort of way
things crossover is for example I read
about a Chinese doctor who was able to
diagnose a heart ailment a very specific
heart ailment from the smell of the
patient's urine whereas you would think
oh you're in ergo gastrointestinal yeah
jumping over to coronary I have a
question it comes from my interesting
history of medicine when people talk
about Western medicine there's often a
conversation about why it is that
bloodletting for example sort of fades
away by the end of the 19th century and
we don't really have a very good
explanation of why that happens would
you see that it happened so I wanted to
ask about traditional Chinese medicine
and I know one of the strengths of the
mid-to-late 20th century is it was
conceived of as timeless or in other
words it could always draw on the past
that there wasn't that sort of break
from the way people did it incorrectly
to the modern way but um I I'd like to
know are there examples in fact of
certain kinds of eye diagnostic or
therapeutic elements where you see
Tichenor z' of Chinese medicine say we
do it this way now we don't do it that
way is there lots and lots because there
there's every kind of mixture of
biomechanical psychological and Chinese
you know multiple systems kinds of ways
of thinking about these things and it's
a good way to make a career to develop
your own hybrid to develop your own
combination of things and so and and
many many modern trained doctors are
rejecting the most of the classical
material on the other hand there are
some of the most innovative in some of
the most elite Li trained doctors with
the best access to all kinds of
biomedical technology and clinical
resources are going back to the classic
books and finding techniques that are
not in the standard TCM textbooks but
they're you know techniques like the
timing of an working out according to
diva nation the proper timing for an
acupuncture intervention right and so
they'll they'll find this system from
some 6th century 7th century work and
they'll work on it and develop it in the
clinic until they've got something that
they think is really worth development
it's taking their reputation on so
there's there's every different kind of
appropriation of and rejection of the
past and for both the appropriation and
the rejection does this become part of
the sort of published research
literature yes more yes and that's
that's one that's been one of the great
eye kind of experiences it is a huge
tragedy that there is this vast
literature when I was at the College
nutritional my medicine
in the early 1980s and this is when
Chinese medicine is just beginning to
revive as a huge field after the
Cultural Revolution there were 27
monthly journals of Chinese medicine in
the library there are many more now and
in these journals there are research
reports there are speculative writing
there's classical scholarship there's if
case reports there's you know my memoirs
of my teachers experience there's all
kinds of fascinating writing all all of
it
promising thoughtful ways of recasting
the resources that are available it's
huge
and so what's frustrating to me and what
I feel is rather a tragedy is that
people here don't even know it exists
they don't even know that these debates
these discussions these conversations
are going on first thank you so much
about your professional lectures and I
really appreciate and as you talked
about the patient's the medicine and the
method and I have heard that the
traditional Chinese medicine doctor will
treat the different patient with
different desserts with the same
medicine and in the same prescription or
the same formula but wearers may be the
trade the same patient with the same
disease but with the different medicine
and the prescription so I guess
according to the different patterns and
what do you think of that well they say
in the textbooks even in the textbooks
but certainly in the classrooms and in
the clinics the doctors will correct me
and other students when we try to
woodenly apply a principle from the
literature from the textbook they'll say
no no we woman sure
humming yes we we we look at illness
according to the time the place and the
person and that means that your for
examinations has to be sensitive enough
to pick up all the specificities of that
case that means that the same doctor
might treat a patient who comes in with
heart she depleted with liver system
involvement or something like that he
might treat six patients in a row in
which he thinks that's the pattern
differently because he knows that these
six patients have different
characteristics yes right so there's
that but also a more difficult and
problematic thing from the point of view
of modern science is a lot of doctors
are in a clinic where you have six
doctors practicing and patients you know
maybe it's a p-wave special clinic a
spleen stomach disorders clinic six
doctors practicing patients come in with
very similar patterns and each doctor
will treat very similar patterns
differently and the question that the
student always asks is well are they all
the right treatment yes the point yes
yeah it's nice to dilemma are they all
the right treatment the doctors will say
they could all be right yes because
there are so many different strategies
that we can so many different pathways
we can take you our analytic resources
and there's you know there there are
plenty of ways to be wrong and their
colleagues will happily point out to
them that they're wrong when they're
wrong yes
but there are also plenty of ways to be
right yes this is the chicken problem
that because we want to prove that
traditional medicine is is the very
useful and it's cracked but you know
that different patterns and different
prescriptions may need a tricky problem
to prove it with the modern science yes
right but as part of the perceived
responsiveness of the field patients
like it they like to feel that they're
going to get a customized a completely
customized treatment and and doctors
feel that this is part of their experts
he said they may not do it exactly like
their colleague does but this is because
they know they have sensitive techniques
yes thank you so much hi thank you I was
intrigued by Bernie Siegel in his
non-conventional approach to treating
cancer patients exceptional cancer
patients and he certainly made inroads
through the Yale medicine medical
medical system as you know so Mike my
thought is this and maybe you could add
to it when a China with Bernie found out
is that there is a lot of self-healing
potential within the individual once
they can tap into some of their own
illness through visualization but more
that what I'm the question is this when
a Chinese doctor does an analysis do
they take into consideration some of the
metaphysical properties what Bernie was
touching upon in his analysis and
approaching perhaps self-healing because
as you know the energy from acupuncture
is phenomenal and it's nothing more than
controlling with the needle the energy
that goes through us
but if we can harness the power of the
individual process so can you give us a
little correlation between that last
that quote I ended on I'm gonna go back
to it next time so I'm not gonna get it
back up on the screen but that quote I
ended on mentioned about an intimate
participation in the changes and the
transformations and the changes that
participation is the carefully chosen
translation of a word that means
participation and I'm gonna emphasize
this a bit more next time I've always
thought of actually don't use this word
tomorrow I don't think in what I've
prepared that I've always thought of
what the Chinese doctor does is nudging
natural process in a more wholesome
direction and that's how they think of
it and you'll see in the language that
will go over tomorrow if you're here
that
that they don't claim to eradicate any
causes they don't claim to radically
transform a pathological process they
claim to join in with it and push it and
adjust its course is the phrase I think
I do use tomorrow right so that's and
you know this is this is a cosmology of
metaphysics of the great way the great
way of nature in which human beings
doctor and patient alike are
participating they don't get to control
it thank you
sure take another question okay
comments and those who see your pain in
the Chinese medicine he said experienced
evolves the medicine so a decision to
see the patient take a long time to make
sure in order to make a proper diagnosis
I'm sorry I can't quite take times yes
yes yeah so the question is by the one
of the audience is among six patients
who is better diagnosed that's not
actually how to say yeah and for you for
sure ten years experience is not
sufficient yeah
but the if you know came back into our
medical practice also takes time to
mature so the I think that is also a
experience people become an important
role and the Western medicine so causal
so far cordon so that much good
experience space is based on thousands
years of experience and for our
evidence-based really we're talking
about this less than 100 years well it's
actually a lot less than that since
we've started trying to build an
evidence base under that name this is
why the evidence-based medicine people
are scrambling so hard they're trying to
get all the data all the big databases
there so they can be drawn on as a kind
of a resource so the feet actually if
you think about the open clan we want to
learn from history but we actually open
for God there's a history there we have
not take advantage of it even including
some of traditional
well we met every other part of the
world the second is never separate wait
wait wait wait this you're saying too
much I wanted this agree with you that
the history is very important to change
medical people which is why even the
radical young doctors the highly trained
scientific doctors that I know in
Beijing are forcing their students to
read case books from the past forcing
their students to analyze prescriptions
from the whole archive they insist that
students read history even beyond the
history textbooks right so there's that
and also the the time issue because
Chinese medicine practice relies so
heavily on experience two kinds of
experience at least one is the
individual clinicians experience who is
drawing on patients experiences which
they tell him and which he can see right
but also the experience as you say of
hundreds of years of recorded practice
and that is thought of as experienced by
Chinese doctors and so now I don't but I
don't want to make this just Chinese
because the point I made at the end of
my first book about Chinese medicine is
that this question of experiences
clinical practice diagnostic virtuosity
wise decision making about therapeutics
everybody in Chinese medical and Western
medical bio medical clinics knows this
too and that's why interns and residents
are had to spend so much time working
under senior residents senior doctors
because everybody knows that clinic
there's no substitute for clinical
experience but but did the only
difference is that in Chinese medicine
because they have been on the defensive
for a hundred years they have had to
make that explicit in their curricula in
pedagogy they've had to say we're going
to teach you how to gain experience and
learn from experience because that's
absolutely crucial they've made it
explicit biomedical teaching has not
made that explicit in they're all the
same way in my understanding yeah I
think we are not in disagreement no I
don't think so well I'm trying to say
he's actually I teach in medical school
mm-hmm yeah what do you see
pharmacology pharmacology okay and the
for the past 15 16 years I've been
working in exploring Chinese medicine in
modern medicine great and I can see the
situation's environment who is changing
as meta fatness the convergence of
concept of so-called Western medicine
and Chinese medicine holistic thinking
is been considered for Chinese medicine
diagnosis and the words we are talking
system biology medicine so there's a lot
of common words yeah oh you have to keep
working on that and the MCOs Scott
missing that convergence
I actually I form a consortium for
globalization of Chinese medicine they
are already 157 member institution
member around the world I think we have
the question this will be the last
question take and I just want to remind
everyone before so radness or question
that we have a lovely reception
following our gathering here thank you
please thank you so much for your talk
I'm gonna ask question that might seem a
little bit far afield but I couldn't
help but think of as I was listening to
your talk about the idea of pattern and
I think about the resonance that pattern
carries in realms within and beyond
medicine that really inspired my
thinking and I'm thinking a lot about
the incursion of this phenomenon of big
data and the ways in which the kind of
phrase of the hour is like pattern
recognition looking at the data and I
just wondered you know what you might
think this because your your mode of
helping us think pattern as knowledge
and thought from traditional Chinese
medicine seems like it could be
incredibly valuable not only in the
context of thinking about our bodies and
our symptoms but the ways in which a
whole new emerging form of digital kinds
of knowledge making are changing
medicine but all kinds of modes of life
so I just wanted to invite you to see if
there was anything there well I think
the the pattern recognition work that's
going on in the field of big data and
systems analysis and so it's really very
fascinating and very important I think
after tomorrow though I might have
developed a slight divergence from their
purposes tomorrow I want to talk about
action and how we can't even think about
thought we can't even see things without
standing on the work that we have to do
as healers as medical people right so
looking through the lens of the
necessity of action the and the
particular limits of possible action you
know there's only so much you can do
under current conditions looking through
that lens back at big data at the all
the things we can know that limits how
we can know that and the Big Data people
are maybe sometimes I see some of these
digital humanities projects and I think
well this is all great but what's the
question they're trying to answer what's
the problem they're trying to solve and
that's what would make it more
ultimately more interesting to me I look
forward to the talk tomorrow okay good
let's thank professor Parker
[Music]